let's Ollie code 84 largest rectangle
and histogram so we're given a bunch of
bar heights and each bar has a width of
1 we want to find out what's the largest
rectangle we can get and return the area
of it so in this case the largest has an
area of 10 width of 2 height 5 another
rectangle we could get as an area 8 this
one has a width of 4 height of 2 another
one has a width of 6 height 1 so area 6
there's also other rectangles we could
get but these are a few of them so if we
just draw the first two bars let's see
if we can notice any patterns from them
so if you look at them the first one is
bigger than the second one
that means for the rectangle of height 2
we can't extend it any farther once we
reach this one we can't extend it any
farther so the biggest rectangle we
could get with height 2 is just this one
right here because there's a little hole
over here so we can't push it any
farther but for this one we can push
since the height is 1 we can kind of
extend it towards the left a little bit
right and use the left rectangle and
since we can't extend the height 2 we
can still extend the height 1 because
there's no there's nothing coming after
it that'll stop us just yet let's look
at the opposite scenario what would
happen if the 1 came before the 2 in
this case the 1 comes first so we can
keep extending it to the right there's
nothing stopping us right and the 2
there's nothing coming after it just yet
they'll stop us so we can actually
extend this height of 2 a little farther
because there's no smaller height that
comes after it so there's no hole right
the third case is if two rectangles were
even right next to each other in this
case we can also keep extending it right
because there's no hole these rectangles
are the same height there's no smaller
rectangle stopping
from being extended farther to the right
so this tells us that the current
heights are going to be an increasing
order because this two cannot be
extended beyond this point so we can
only compute the area of height 2 from
this width and then we have to pop it
right we can't extend it any farther so
we have to remove it from being
considered so now let's look at the case
where all the heights are in increasing
order
notice how since they're all in
increasing order they can be extended to
the right continuously right so this one
over here can continue to be extended to
the right this too can be extended to
the right this three can be extended to
the right and this four can be extended
to the right none of them can be
extended towards the left though right
because the height to the left is
smaller so they can't be extended to the
left but what would happen if we
introduced a smaller height after so if
we introduced a three over here that
would mean that this four over here it
can't be extended any farther because
there's a three coming after it so all
we can do is say okay these are the
boundaries of height four let's compute
the area which is going to be 4 in this
case because the width is 1 and then we
have to remove this from being
considered right so we pop it what if we
introduced a 2 instead well the same
thing will happen we can't extend this
for any farther right so all we can say
is these are the boundaries of it right
it's we started back here and then we
extended all the way until we got to
this 2 so compute the area and then pop
it right let's look at this 3 now we
can't extend this any farther either
right because the 2 is less than the 3
so we can say that these are the
boundaries of the 3 let's see what the
area it could have contributed was it's
6 maybe that's the max area we don't
know yet but well you know we can't
extend this three any farther so we have
to pop it as well what about this 2 over
here
well since the new height that we got is
also 2 we can keep extending it there's
an there's no reason we can't so we will
all
you have to pop these two elements the
three and the four because we can't
extend them any farther because now we
reached a two let's look at one last
example to drive this point home so now
we have a one over here right so we
can't extend the four anymore either so
we compute the area four and then remove
it from consideration also this three it
can't be extended any further so we
compute the area six and then remove it
from consideration in this case even the
two can't be extended any further right
because the one is too small so we
compute the area in this case six and
then remove it from consideration so in
this case we had a 1 and then we popped
three elements from consideration right
so notice how we are popping elements
and we're only popping the most recent
elements we're not popping an element
that's in the middle
we're only popping them from the top to
the bottom from the most recent elements
right so that tells us we should use a
stack for this problem so the stack will
contain the current heights that are
that we are considering and we'll pop
them from the top when we are no longer
considering them so now let's look at
the algorithm so I have a stack and in
the stack I'm not just gonna hold the
index and I'm not just gonna hold the
height I'm gonna hold both of them at
the same time so I'm holding the start
index and the corresponding height I'm
also gonna be maintaining what the max
area is so far so now let's start at the
beginning of the array we get element
two so since there's nothing in the
stack we can't pop anything let's just
add it so I that's starting at index
zero we have a height of two next we get
to index one there's a height of one
over here right so now we're gonna add
the height one to our stack but let's
notice let's look at our stack there's a
height one that's at the top of the
stack right now that means that this -
it can't be extended any farther we
reached a height
was smaller than the two so that means
we're gonna pop the two from the stack
but before we pop it let's just see
what's the max area we could have gotten
with this to height so it started at
index zero right we can see it started
at index zero and it and we just reached
index one so that's the range of the
width from zero to one so the width is
one the height is two so that means the
area is two so so far we'll say our max
area is two now and now we can pop the
two from the stack so what's the index
of this one now
well we're currently at index one right
so we can say that that's the index but
I'm actually gonna do it a little
differently if you look at this two we
can actually extend this one all the way
back because we just popped this - that
means this one could have been extended
back by one so instead of saying the
index of this one of this height one
starts at index one I'm gonna say it
starts at index zero because we can
extend it all the way back to the zero
over here next we're gonna get at index
two we have a five right so we'll add
that to our stack the five is greater
than the one so there's no restriction
this one can still be extended so I'll
just add the five and the corresponding
index which is two to the stack don't
need to pop anything next we get to
index three right there's a height of
six again this six is greater than this
than the value at the top of our stack
which is five so the heights are in
increasing order so far which is good
that means we don't have to pop anything
and the index we reach the six was at
three
that means this five can continue to be
extended that's why we don't have to pop
the five now we get to index for this is
where the interesting stuff happens so
well so this at this index four we have
a height - the problem is this six now
can't go any farther we reached a two so
this six which started at index 3 over
here ended up stopping at index 4 that
means its width was only one so we have
to pop it now but before we pop it let's
get that
area that it could have made so from in
depth so the width is one the height is
six that means the area it could have
made is six this is the max area that
this height of six could have created so
we'll update our max area six is greater
than two our max area is now six and
let's pop this six from the stack
okay now the top of our stack is five
but wait
five is greater than the two as well
that means this five can't be extended
any farther so we look at the start
index of this five it was index two and
we stopped it all the way index four so
that means its width was to its height
is five so the area it created was 10 so
before we pop it let's just compute the
max area that it could have created it's
10 so we update our max area our max
area is now 10 greater than 6 and we
remember to pop this 5 from our stack
now we look at the top of the stack it's
1 right 2 is greater than 1 so we don't
have to pop this one because this one
can continue to be extended so we don't
have to pop it right and what about the
start index do we put for this height of
2 can we put index 4 well yes we can but
we notice that we just popped two
elements 6 and 5 that means this 2 can
actually be extended backwards all the
way to index 2
right so instead of saying index 4 is
the start value of this - I'm gonna say
index 2 next we reach index 5 the last
element so this height is 3 let's put it
on our stack we see 3 is greater than 2
that means we don't have to pop the 2
from the stack that means that this 2
can continue to be extended there's no
need to pop it and what about the start
index of this height 3
well we can't extend it backwards
anymore so I'm just gonna say the start
index is 5 if you look we still have the
elements left in our stack so what do we
do with them so we have three elements
that we didn't end up popping from the
stack what that tells us is that we were
able to extend them all the way to the
end of the histogram so we still need to
compute the areas we could have created
from these heights
so let's iterate through them and figure
that out so let's start at this last one
index five it started and it had a
height of three so it started at index
five and went all the way to the end of
the histogram so that means the length
of it was just one the height is three
so we can compute the area as having an
area of three right
now this area of three is not greater
than our current max of ten so we don't
update our max let's go to the next
element in our stack it's indexed to
height two that means it started at
index two over here and it went all the
way to the end of the histogram and it
had a height of two so that means the
width was four
the height was to two times four is
eight so the area it created was eight
eight is not greater than our max area
either the max areas 10 so we don't
update the max area the last element in
our stack index zero height one that
tells us it started all the way back
here at index zero and it extended all
the way to the end of the histogram so
from zero to the end is a width of six
the height was one so that means the
area it created was six this six is not
greater than our current max area of ten
either so that means the max area at the
end is ten so that's the result 10 so
with this algorithm we only had to
iterate through the histogram once we
had to push elements onto our stack but
we had to only push each element once
and pop it once so that means the
overall time complexity is Big O of N
we had to use a stack and the stack
could potentially be up to the entire
size of the of the input array so we did
need extra memory the memory is also
going to be Big O of n ok now let's
write the code so we know we have to
keep track of what the max area
currently is so I'm going to initially
say the max area is 0 we also know we
have to have a stack in Python we can
use just a list to do that and in my
stack I'm going to hold a pair of
elements the pair of elements is gonna
be an index and the height so now let's
iterate through the index and height of
this Heights array before I add it to
the stack I'm gonna say the start index
of this current height that we're at is
just I because we don't know if we can
extend it backwards just yet so let's
now check if our stack is not empty and
if the stack if the top value in the
stack and the top values height is
greater than the height that we just
reached if that's the case that means we
have to pop our stack right we have to
pop the height and we have to check the
max rectangle we can create from that
height and we have to extend the current
height that we're at backwards so now we
have to pop from the stack because this
height is too great right so we're
popping but we have to actually retrieve
the values who are popping so we're
popping in index and we're popping the
height and we have to check if this
height that we're popping could have
been the max area rectangle
we're gonna multiply the height by the
width we can compute the width pretty
easily right now we're at the current
index we're at is I and the index that
this height started out was what we just
popped index so I minus index is going
to be the width and since we know that
this height was greater than the current
height that were visiting that means we
can extend our start index backwards to
the index that we just popped now when
we actually add our element to the stack
or add our pair to the stack we're gonna
say we're gonna add the pair start index
and the height that we're visiting right
now we're not just adding I we're adding
the start index that we pushed all the
way backwards and now we remember there
still might be some entries in our stack
left so these were able to be extended
all the way to the end of the histogram
so we still have to compute their
heights and we can do that pretty easily
so we potentially update our max area
the height is just what's stored in the
stack so height multiplied by the width
we can compute the width pretty easily
we know that these were extended all the
way to the end of the histogram so we
can get the length of the histogram
subtracted by the start value I that was
stored in the stack and now all we have
to do is return our max area and it
works perfectly I think this is the most
intuitive solution at least from my
perspective for this problem storing I
think the start index and the height in
the stack makes it a little easier